it's too bad Trump can't vote because if
he could he'd vote for himself again
after hearing this thrilling him
announcement this week President Trump
sign space policy directive one
yesterday which sets in motion sending
astronauts back to the moon this time we
will not only plant our flag and leave
our footprint we will establish a
foundation for an eventual mission to
Mars that's right baby
we're going to the moon then Mars and
then some other planets that Trump
hasn't even discovered yet
look at this efficiency truck downsize
the astronauts so we can fly them to
space the cake we can just strap that
little guy to a bottle rocket with all
this forget all this tom hanks houston
we have a problem
just leave it to the squashing tiss it
there phasers to complain and bitch
about how trump's order had no timeline
and promise no funding for future
missions listen listen to these
crybabies this executive order is full
of information just look at it yeah what
else do you need wake up NASA this is
the future
are you astronauts or pastoring ops
because the president took a hard look
at the Sun and said that's too shiny to
land on no no we're going to the moon
and then beyond don't you remember the
60s when John F Kennedy a Democrat
called for a moon landing and they
planted their leftist flag claiming the
moon as some future liberal Haven full
of juice cleanses and Bernie Sanders sex
robots the moon it's old news Trump his
plans to get us on Mars by I quote his
second term at worst
yeah second term let that confidence
wash over you
and once we're on Mars we'll have
exactly what we've always wanted a
conservative planet so what if we lost
Alabama this week Mars is the Alabama of
the solar system it's literally the red
planet it's named after the god of
perpetual war ding-ding-ding we have a
winner
conservatives can finally say goodbye to
this clunker of a planet leaving
liberals to focus on climate change and
achieving whatever the word for non war
is because we'll be busy putting a
cowboy boot print on the surface of a
real planet planting a flag so big you
can see it on earth and watching truly
inspiring moments like this this is one
big league step for man and one even
bigger step for Donald Trump who has
giant feet because you know why bet your
wishes thought of that one Buzz
Lightyear
[Music]